[Music]
2019 is going to be a very busy year for
a chess what are your thoughts as a
chess player and as a pan about this
year's calendar when they didn't go very
well for me so I'm hoping that will be
my comeback year this is the year where
I'm planning to come back to play since
the London Classic I haven't really
played any competitive chess besides for
small online games so yeah I'm really
ready to get back into it okay I already
played the vacancy which was a very
special event as well for me I have one
super tournament coming up in Prague it
seems it will be a crazy era because
that nine tournaments but I'm happy with
it and while I'm looking forward as a
fan I think it's great because fans are
gonna get to watch events pretty much
non-stop from about me through the end
of the year so as a fan you're not
you're really not spoiled in terms of
the choice as a player I don't know have
that excited obviously I'm travelling
way too much the cooperation between
Grantchester and Grand Prix was very
good and many events are not clashing
with each other
Grantchester have multiplied the
environment and now we have six or seven
Grantchester event for me personally
it's going to be a tough but challenging
year so I'm looking forward to it but ok
I need to prepare well and to spare some
energy to be able to play well also in
some tournaments when they come next to
each other more than anything it's gonna
be a test of endurance in terms of who
can maintain the highest level Chester
out because everyone's gonna be
traveling left and right I'm also
playing in the Grand Prix series
hopefully to qualify for the candidates
we also have the World Cup this year and
the grand Swiss it's gonna be hectic
we're gonna be gone a really long time
for me it's actually not as busy because
I didn't qualify for the Fida Grand Prix
I was very I never very narrowly missed
the event I'm certainly most looking
forward to as the world
I've said over and over again I'll say
it again I love knockout tournaments I
think that's the way chess should be run
and I think now I'm strong enough to
really make a run to essentially get
farther than like the second round where
I got knocked out
but for these times I mean I'm not
planning to play too many events and
basically hit I just get rest from home
homework so I can rest for my kids